so I'm going to talk about three
different things in this video one I'm
going to talked about the number one
reason why so many entrepreneurs lose
momentum and for you to learn exactly
what this reason is and do whatever you
can for this to never ever happen to you
the second thing I'm going to talk to
you about is a question that I asked
this past weekend so many people and
nobody had a specific clear answer to
this question I'm gonna ask you and the
third one is a video I made three years
ago that I want you to watch that will
address everything about momentum having
said that let me get right into it the
number one reason why so many
entrepreneurs lose momentum is because
of start stop
let me explain to what I mean by start
stop they start they get excited oh my
gosh I'm gonna figure this out
I'm gonna pull this off on my get after
another yeah I'm so motivated because
I'm gonna do for my mom my dad my
husband my wife myself our this is so
great and they go from making 3 grand a
month 5 grandmas oh my gosh 10 grand a
month 15 20 30 a month and in that 30
momme whatever that number is all of
Senegal from 30 a month to 17 to nine to
four thousand dollars month and they
lost momentum so what happened there
because if start stopped they start and
then they stop now why do they stop
maybe their stomach at four maybe they
got casual maybe they got cocky maybe
started coming to office a little later
maybe they thought they knew it on they
became this motivational speaker I'm
just gonna go and speak all over the
place that's what I'm gonna be doing and
a business starts dropping but they
those things become the cause of a
business dropping so now why does that
happen
if it starts stop what causes somebody
to have so many start stops very simple
the question that most people don't have
the answer to is who do you want to be
in life let me ask you one more time who
do you want to be in life who what kind
of a life do you want to live what do
you mean by who do I want to be in life
who do you want to be in life do you
know what you want to do is it just the
cars is it just for people to say you're
cool is it just a house it's just uh you
know money is it just uh accolades to
fame is that what it is what is it you
want to make an impact
what is your life gonna be worth one day
what are people gonna say about you when
you die
the eulogy is gonna be written what are
they gonna say about you who do you want
to be on life how are you kids gonna
remember you what are your parents gonna
say about you what are your siblings
gonna say about you when your friend's
gonna say about you what's the school
gonna say about you or is it just one of
those things boom you disappear and
you're gone and people come to your
funeral one time and maybe they show up
on seer and then afterwards you're just
forgotten about and you know why that
happens because most people have no clue
who they want to be in life and I know
that sounds kind of strange but people
just have no idea who they want to be in
life you see years ago I sat down and
this thing I'm recording with this phone
is the number one reason why so many
people don't know who they want to be in
life because they say we touch this
phone 150 times a day that means we
don't have a chance to get away from
newsfeed Instagram all this content we
consume to actually sit down and ask
this simple question who do you want to
be in life what kind of a life you want
to live what do you want to do with your
kids what do you want to do with your
wife your husband what kind of a life
you want to live do you know the answer
to those questions and so whatever that
dream is you can be so oh I want to be
this I want to be that the bigger the
dream is the longer your run has to be
without you stopping let me explain if
your dream is to be a billionaire maybe
you got to go on a twenty thirty you run
if you dream is to be a millionaire
maybe you got to go on a ten-year run if
your dream is to make a quarter million
maybe you got to go on a three to
five-year run if your dream is to just
make six figures maybe you got to go on
a twelve to an 18-month run but whatever
that run is you cannot stop and every
time you stop that dream gets more
distant and distant and this goes away
and away away from you why because
you're stopping and to achieve the life
that you want to live requires momentum
to be in your favor so number one reason
why so many entrepreneurs lose momentum
is start stop number two reason is who
do you want to be in life they don't
have the answer to that question think
about it when I ask you that question
did you automatically have the answer
did you say well I want so if you do
that you don't know it yet you got to
write it down if you do write it down
I'd love to know some people that
actually know who they want to be in
life what kind of life they want to live
last but not least the video I've told
you that I'm gonna recommend for you to
watch is a video I made three years ago
called
how to really become a millionaire I'm
gonna put the link below for you to go
out and watch watch that video it's an
old video I have a new one that's called
how to make a million dollar income you
can watch that one as well but how to
make them and how to really make them
how to really be a millionaire I give
very specific formulas where a lot of
people don't like and there's a lot of
controversy with this video but I want
you to go watch their video how to
really become a millionaire and after
you watch that video comment and let me
know if you finally know who you want to
be in life take everybody let's have a
killer week this week